well hi everyone thank you so so much
for having me over today and giving me
the chance to share my story and
background and the work that that work
that I've done today in order to help
people with disabilities using tech so
today I just want to give a bit of a
whistle-stop tour of the story behind
the common ball and how we ended up at
air B&B but also hopefully leave you
with some take-home messages about how
investing in accessibility can be really
valuable from both just in terms of
inclusion but also as a business
opportunity and give you all something
to think about as hopefully one day you
end up building building products
yourself so as mentioned my name is
Schwinn I share this photo for two
reasons one to prove that I once had I
once had hair and good looks the second
reason is this photo was taken about a
week before I was diagnosed with a
condition called spinal muscular atrophy
so it's it's a neuromuscular condition
that means I don't really have much
movement in my arms and legs and since
since I can remember I have used a
wheelchair for mobility um I have a team
of carers and nurses that support me
around the clock and I've sort of used
the assistive technology since since day
one you know I think I I think I learnt
to type on a computer or use voice
activation before I even knew how to
hold a pen so for me technology not just
on the business side has had sort of a
transfer transformational impact to
allow me to live my life since day one
and as you can see today I'm sitting in
a pretty high tech powered wheelchair
that allows me to get around and do and
do whatever I want to do as we said in
the introduction and as you can tell
from my accent I am not from here I am
from London and this is the cheesiest
photo of London that I could find on the
Internet and so yes I was born and
brought up in London and moved to San
Francisco a couple of years ago as
mentioned I'm from London I originally
trained to be an attorney and I and I
practice law for nearly five years so I
was an M&A guy
and had the most amazing time learnt a
ton but was just not really something
that I felt resonated with me in the
long term
I've always enjoyed building things and
just making things and trying stuff out
and just the the life inside a law firm
at the time was just not for me and so
up until about 2011 I'd never really
traveled I'd only ever gone on those
vacations that parent's 40 to go on to
meet relatives that you don't really
want to visit and like I'd always wanted
to go on more exciting adventures all of
my friends had gone traveling and I'm so
I've seen so many cool places and so
many times they would share those
experiences and I'd be like oh you know
I wish I could do that and because I had
never really done anything and so I took
those six months off to see whether it
was possible so with one of my really
two of my care assistants booked a bunch
of trips not really knowing what to
expect I had the most amazing time it
was an experience where I went all
around Europe went to many parts of the
US went on a camping safari in South
Africa and learned to scuba dive in Bali
as you can see from the photo um and you
know this was from an adapted diving
centre in Bali wherever I turned up to a
big flight of steps and I and I asked
that why how is this adapted and there
were six guys saying that we will help
you and not exactly quite adapted but
you know it was it was an amazing
experience
however things didn't always go to plan
so lots of times I would use well-known
travel websites and things that were
supposedly accessible clearly weren't so
this is actually not a photo from that
trip but just goes to show you what
people with disabilities often have to
face when traveling so this is actually
an registered listed ad a accessible
room at a major hotel chain clearly as
you can see it is not possible to use
this hotel room the bed is too there the
the width between the bed and the
furniture is far too narrow I simply
couldn't I couldn't use it and this
actually was about 11:30 at night when I
arrived and then I had to find other
accommodation in the middle
the night just after coming off 11 hour
flight from London to the Bay Area and
actually on that trip I remember another
experience I I a place that I had booked
the property owner claimed to not have
steps at there at the home turned up to
see three steps and I asked her property
owner why did you say it had three steps
the property owner said well it does
have well it's step three but you have
to get past the first three steps and so
yeah these are the kinds of challenges
and barriers that people faced when
traveling with a disability and so fast
forward about three years I went back to
school again as I mentioned I I did an
MBA at Oxford and and on the program I
was very fortunate enough to get to know
some engineers and I always thought our
you know I'm too old to learn to code
and this is that very gratefully some of
these people said that's absolutely
nonsense and started to help me learn to
code so by the time you know fast
forward two years later I'd learnt quite
a lot of sort of Ruby on Rails
programming I had done a load of sort of
online courses and a lot of times just
taught myself well by the time I'd
graduated I was starting off as a
basically working as a freelance web
developer making basic web apps for
whoever needed anything and I just
rolled off a really big project and also
on the side with my friend Martin here
this is from from our trip in 2011 mm
yeah round then in California we thought
to ourselves you know could we build
something interesting and cool that
could help people with disabilities
travel so you know Martin and I went
back a long way
childhood friends who both love to
travel and we'd had a bunch of side
projects where we were running a
lifestyle magazine just to share
information and advice on accessible
travel and so in the summer of 2015 I
effectively just locked myself in my
bedroom for about 20 days and hacked
together a very basic prototype of what
became a comma ball now I don't know
whether it shows very well on the
projector screen but there were two
unique things about what we built
so the first was that we had lots of
different filters so normally a website
may have just had a box called a
wheelchair-accessible
we took that box out and actually had
lots of different things it could be
grab rails rollin showers medical
equipment loads of different things that
people could search for and that we had
verified was accurate the second thing
of them we also used to joke about was
we had more toilets on the website than
any other website out there and sort of
joking aside like it's something really
important to see really good bathroom
pictures when you are traveling with
accessibility needs the bathroom is so
important and it's so vital for your own
dignity to be able to use it and so we
were meticulous in collecting
photography and making sure that if
somebody said they had those things you
could see on the photo whether it was
there or not so as you can see from that
photo is one of our first listings in
Barcelona the shower is perfectly
rolling the grab rails are solid and
there is space under the sink and so I
shared this product just on social media
just to see what people would think and
I think just wanted to reiterate this
actually wasn't a business at the time
it was just a fun project with a couple
of friends just to see whether we could
help friends our community our family
find somewhere good to stay when going
on vacation and I've always been sort of
inspired by sort of the approach of like
when you're building something to be as
hands-on as possible and to do
everything as manually as possible at
the beginning to kind of learn from your
users so after building the prototype
and seeing that we were getting some
initial traction I effectively sort of
went on the road so I had an absolute
superhero of a of a support worker a
care assistant me and him basically did
about three and a half four thousand
miles around Europe for three months and
we would source list we would source
recommendations on social media and I
would just contact that person and say
hey look you know would it be possible
to stay with you I would go there and
sort of build the product around your
user and effectively you know
I would stay there I'd ask for feedback
iterate the product again and I come
very much from sort of like a rapid
prototyping background where you're
constantly looking to improve the
product push code out again and actually
this is a photo of me staying at one of
the listings we had in instead of the
the Catalan region of Spain that day the
website broke down so I literally had to
push a fix on the edge of a mountain and
so we pushed this site out and lo and
behold we actually had some we had some
people were using it which was like the
most incredible experience ever
and our first customer was Suzanne from
Belfast in Northern Ireland which is a
part of the UK and she'd gone on her
first ever trip to Barcelona and sent us
this know afterwards saying a coma boy
allowed me to experience my first girls
holiday with my best friends and then
she sort of added a note on to that was
saying that this was like the first
steps to independence and I was just
really grateful for like that we had
enabled her to travel for the first time
and so were like okay awesome what do we
do now I've got a business on our hands
so what started then was probably like
two of the craziest rollercoaster years
ever when we realized that there was a
nucleus of an idea here and that this
could grow we raised we raised a load of
money from venture capital investors in
London and grew to a eight-person team
and over the course of that two years we
we got over 2,000 listings and with
properties in just over 60 countries and
things were growing really fast and
really well but the problem we had was
that we had way too much demand and not
enough supply so it just have sort of
provides some context for everytin
booking request that we were getting we
could only satisfy one of them at a time
and some of our property owners were
taking bookings two years in advance
that was the level of like demand and
the need that this community had and
what a shortage of supply there was and
also at the time you know there's many
engineers in the room and I'm sure that
you've come across this when trying to
build things just as
products start to grow they start to
break and so we were getting a lot of
users on the site and trying to build
infrastructure to support that growth
was beginning to be a really big
challenge for us and we were needing a
lot more resource in order to scale much
further so early on in 2017 which
started a series a funding round um so
this is a funding round just after seed
stage where you know you usually look to
raise sort of between two and three
million in order to take sort of initial
kind of products that has earlie product
market fit to scale it to a much larger
area and for us as well we were very
driven and passionate about taking the
solution that we had sort of prototyped
and being able to take it to a much
global audience and I think you know
from the get-go
we started this because we wanted to
help people and wanted to solve this
problem for people with disabilities so
they could travel everywhere so we would
ask this question to ourselves how do we
take this to a much more global level so
we started this funding round and very
early on some of my advisers and
investors said hey why don't you talk to
the big travel platforms and see whether
you know there could be some tie up or
whether the infrastructure you need
could be sourced from a big player like
Airbnb for instance and so one of my
investors made an introduction to
somebody at senior at Airbnb I came out
here in the summer of 2017 and started a
whole series of conversations with a
completely open mind we had no you know
we didn't really have a goal as to what
any kind of partnership or collaboration
could be but very quickly the
conversation moved to words on the air
B&B side actually if we want to take
this solution and be able to scale it to
a global audience the best thing would
be to acquire a common ball and my team
to work at Airbnb and so in November
2017 we closed the acquisition so a
common ball was acquired by Airbnb with
very much the mindset that we would
infuse accessibility within Airbnb on a
much global level and I would move from
London to San Francisco to build out
this new team and grew
so I was the only one from my team that
moved to San Francisco the rest are
still in in London working on other
parts of accessibility at air B&B so I
just want to take a step back so we've
moved over so I've moved over from
London to San Francisco but also just
here now I wanted to take the time to
think about why this area is actually
really important and why I think many
sort of future entrepreneurs in this
room today it's something really
valuable to think about so firstly it's
a well reported statistic from the World
Health Organization that a billion
people in the world have a disability of
some kind now there's many different
types of built with disabilities across
a broad spectrum but I think if we just
sort of hold on there and think about
that statistic that is a huge number of
people and often an a massively untapped
audience that many companies
organizations don't often think about
now for those of you who have worked in
accessibility before on sort of the tech
side at our sort of what comes to mind
when you think about tech and
accessibility and I imagine a lot of it
is things like you know digital
accessibility compliance and does it you
know comply with sort of w3c standards
and is it Double A or lots of kind of
you know well-established and very vital
compliance and accessibility measures to
make sure that a website is digitally
accessible however as the online and
offline worlds are converging we need to
think about how accessibility can be
baked when technology is facilitating
the use of a real world product and so I
have some examples here whether it be a
self-driving car or an Alexa an Alexa
echo device or home automation or even a
Exeter on-demand transport like uber how
are all these products and services
going to be usable for people with
disabilities when maybe even the
foundational fundamental product itself
may not have been built for
accessibility in mind but when those
products and services are becoming so
vital and important how do we make sure
people can actually
use them and for me so the anecdote I
share even though things are much better
now when I first moved from London to
San Francisco one of my biggest
struggles was the fact there was no
transportation so at the time uber and
lyft did not provide any accessible
vehicles as part of as part of their
service as it was literally impossible
to get a taxi of any kind around San
Francisco luckily now fortunately things
have changed and there is a lot more
service but when I first got to San
Francisco I was completely felt
completely stranded because I couldn't
use the same transport services that
everybody else could use and so that
poses the question when offline and
online converge how do we ensure
accessibility and I think it's a really
important but also a very complex
question that sits at the intersection
of Technology Policy product development
design and has a lot of really complex
societal questions that we collectively
need to think about and so coming back
to kind of what we were doing at a comma
boy and now air B&B so when I started in
November 2017 we often say it started
sort of the new beginning sort of in the
world of accessibility where we launched
something called the in home
accessibility team now from the outset I
need to add a one sort of caveat where
you know the the work that my team does
is focus very much on how do we
facilitate the real world product to be
usable on Airbnb and the second caveat
is like we had to start and focus on
something so for the first 18 months our
focus has been very much on physical
mobility and how do we ensure that
travel is accessible from that
perspective but with a view to one day
making sure that actually other people
with other types of disabilities can use
the product just like anybody else so
firstly new team and this is just a
photo of the team we are you know a team
full of engineers designers data
scientists operations people the entire
spectrum just over 20 people and for
those of you who don't know it's at IBM
has a big vision statement with
mission to create a world where anyone
can belong anywhere and you know I'll
sort of submitted within that team is
that we need to make sure that that
ability to belong anywhere includes
people with disabilities and so out from
the team's vision is to create the most
trusted travel platform for guests with
accessibility needs so how do we reach
this vision so firstly we don't just
think about accommodation even though
our focus is just on accommodation now
we often chart out the entire process of
travel whether it be like what to look
for how to plan for it where to find
accommodation things to do what services
and see is a very holistic thing we also
see it very much is a big multi-year
project where we have to work with lots
of stakeholders in lots of parts of the
world in order to make this better and
so when I started I posed three complex
questions and even to this date we're
still working on answering them so
number one how do you accurately collect
accessibility information across
millions of listings across the world
now there is no one definition for
accessibility many counties many cities
many countries all have their own
definition of what is accessibility and
actually again we joke in our team
sometimes some of our biggest
philosophical questions are trying to
define what is a step or what should we
define a step to be is that a quarter
inch it's a half inch what if it's half
inch with a slightly rounded edge and so
we go round in circles trying to define
these standards because no one's ever
done it before and again in various
countries of the world where
accessibility has not been considered
how do we think about educating and how
communicating that information to hosts
around the world
in order to add that information
question to um as you know sort of
Airbnb the bulk of Airbnb is people
sharing private homes that can be booked
and the question then then comes how do
you find listings that have higher
levels of accessibility information when
many homes around the world were not
built with those sorts of standards in
mind
and finally when you have a large
platform of hosts around the world how
do you make them more aware of
accessibility in the first place so I'm
gonna give you a quick sort of
Whistlestop tour of some of the products
and services that we're trying to build
in our team so first we've even started
there and I the one of my big take home
messages today is whatever you are
building whether it be accessibility
related or any kind of problem for
people you start with empathy and trying
to understand people
so we've regularly run focus groups and
research with the local disability
community whenever we are testing
products we make sure that those
products are tested and we're getting
feedback we're making sure that many
people in our team and across the
research function are having that
exposure and like learning firsthand
from people the experience of traveling
and actually that first-hand experience
is really vital when you are building
product secondly I spend a lot of my
time engaging disability communities
around the world so this is a photo of
an open house that we did in Los Angeles
where effectively you know we we we had
decent amounts of food and drink and had
an open invite to the local disability
community just to come here about our
work and where I could be really
transparent about a the challenges that
we face and be what our bigger picture
and roadmap is just to get the community
really excited about what we're trying
to do and feel like they're part of the
journey as well and so a lot of that
research and that empathy and that
direct contact of people allowed us to
build a roadmap of what we can actually
build and so again first thing we did
when we got there there was this one
wheelchair accessible tick box that you
know it's very difficult to understand
so we took that out and replaced it with
all the different filters that we once
had many of which we had a common ball
but were adapted for air B&B so again
things like roll-in showers grab rails
all the different features
that were once on a Commodore these were
sort of adapted to be to be to be within
Airbnb now we're there being the host
create listings and they can add photos
in order to prove things so one of the
things that we did when we first started
was install in order for people just in
order for a host to be able to
understand what they could select we
made it mandatory to add a photo so if
you say that you have a grab rail or a
roll in shower you can only tick the box
by adding a photo and so this is just
some screenshots of how it looks now for
hosts where they get some in product
education they have to add photos and we
provide some training about what exactly
they need to do and again this was a
really good example of it's a complex
engineering challenge to rebuild a lot
of photography uploading systems but
also making sure that we can do this
with our users in mind that they can do
this also with an ability to understand
what accessibility is if you're a host
again as a legacy system Airbnb had a
lot of accessibility information where
there was not photography so we ran a
retro so we are running a retrospective
exercise where we are asking the host to
add photos or have accessibility
information deselected from their
listing and while that might sound
pretty kind of a cute and harsh sort of
Alf our belief is we want to have a
really good service where even if there
are less listings we'd rather have them
really accurate with really good
photography so again this is just a
little of a few screenshots of what
hosts see now when they are asked to add
photos or face information and being
deselect accessibility information being
deselected from the listing and again
that's been a great prompt to make sure
those for that photography is there
before a lot of accessibility
information on the listing was pretty
hidden and not very easily discoverable
we've bumped that to the top when it's
now much easier to find and also we did
a whole load of engineering work where
if somebody does stay at a listing and
we know that they've searched
using the accessibilty filters they will
get a follow-up review questionnaire
afterwards asking about this day and
whether all the accessibility features
that they thought were in the listing
whether they were actually there or not
and again it's just been really popular
with guests to be able to have that
review flow tailored to them and then
finally as mentioned where we're asking
host to add photographs to their listing
and we're still thinking a lot about how
do we make sure even those photographs
are as good as possible so one of my
most liked favorite projects this year
is where we've actually partnered with
disability community groups in the Bay
Area and we've been working with their
membership in a pilot program where
we've been paying them to review photos
on listings for us in order to give
feedback to the hosts so this was a
short you know two-month pilot that we
ran earlier in the year but it was
really popular and again we got great
feedback from people with the lived
experience because yeah they know what
they need is somebody with accessibility
needs and were able to provide really
good feedback on on photography and so
again this is just a screenshot of it
it's a very basic tool where an
evaluator would be shown a photo the
host would have said you know we think
this is step 3
does it have these we think it has these
things and then they evaluator would
just go through a checklist to see
whether the photo had all of these
different items in that in that photo
and if not to be able to provide
feedback and then the other big tract of
work again it's not just about
technology even though I'm guessing
everybody in the room today cares about
engineering and product we look of it as
just to start like no matter how good a
product you engineer there has to be
their educational layer on top in order
to empower the people that you're
building products for so we have a
network of photographers around the
world and so we've been training those
photographers on how to take better
pictures of listings should they have
accessibility and I think the best its
showcased I think really evidently in
the next slide we
again it's a before-and-after so the
photo on the left you could not tell
much about that shower after some
training and some education that photo
is so much easier to tell that it's so
much easier to tell on that photo that
that shower has a shower chair there's a
solid grab rail there and it's step free
to enter and again simple educational
interventions that have provided a
transformational experience on that
listing that somebody can now see it and
book it just like anybody else again
another simple example the photo on the
left doesn't tell you much but after
some training the photo on the right is
so much more evident to see that this
listing is so much more usable and then
finally like if you're interested
we've been housing a lot of the work
that we've been doing on a simple
website airbnb.com forward slash
accessibility as part of our program
just to be really transparent about
where we're at on what we would like to
do and then on the subject of sort of
education so this year I feel like I've
spent most of the time sort of on a
plane we have run over 20 workshops
we're with host real-life workshops
around the world where again we bring in
local folks with disabilities to share
their travel experiences we ask our top
performing hosts in that area to listen
to a short talk about accessibility why
it's important and how they can create a
great experience for guests and the
importance of making sure that whatever
they have in their listing is
communicated really clearly and so again
just a chart of where we've had some
workshops this year I have yeah I went
to a lot of different places and I've
got to run and I've been able to run
workshops in Europe America and and in
Asia and it's just been a really
exciting experience just to be able to
evangelize the work that we're doing to
a global audience and again like coming
back to sort of the real world aspect
no matter sort of how
the tech is it is about real people and
being able to improve people's lives and
this was a quote that a host sent to us
after coming to one of our training
sessions they updated their listing with
accessibility information a guest tried
to book that listing or be it was not
able to make the booking because
calendars did align but found the
information on that listing really
helpful and sent the host a note just
thanking them profusely about how having
this information made their life and
product experience so much better and
this actually wasn't a technological
thing this was simply being mindful
about how we communicate how we educate
people in order to create a better
experience alongside having that
technological product there as well and
so you know as much as sort of we're
doing this at air B&B and making a
really concerted an intentional
investment to improve things I really do
think there are some other cool things
that other companies are doing as well
and again it involves around sort of
trying to bridge the offline and online
experience so I don't know how this is
actually performed in the big picture
but Tommy Hilfiger now have an adaptive
line of clothing where you know that
they have clothing ranges that are more
easier to use if you are a wheelchair
user or if you've had a prosthetic limb
and they've just really thought about
how they can modify clothing to make it
easier if you have an accessibility need
about 18 months ago I think Google
launched a new service on Google Maps
where they were adding accessible
navigation routes on on Google Maps this
was a really great example of an
intervention where it had nothing to do
with the accessibility of Google Maps
itself but they were using their
technology to find real-world
information so you could discover it on
Google Maps and here is the Xbox
adaptive controller that Microsoft
created again a couple of years ago this
was a controller made to make the Xbox
easy it
use for folks who have accessibility
needs I thought this was a really cool
example of a company making an
investment to make their product or
service easier to use and an adaptive
controller it was that actually it
wasn't just for one type of disability I
think there's lots of different kinds of
disabilities that this controller
considers when it's being used in real
life so again it's it's an example of
where it's even though the Microsoft a
game or whatever the product was may
have could hit compliance on an
accessibility standard here Microsoft
have made the the the investment to make
sure that the controller allows somebody
with a disability to use it and just a
great example of converging technology
with the real life experience here are
just some sort of some take-home
messages that I'd love to leave with
with you all today that is hopefully
covered in some of these slides firstly
as mentioned start with empathy and
speak to speak to users with
disabilities make sure you test what you
build it array and make sure you're
testing with that audience to get that
feedback one thing that a lot of
companies and organizations struggle
with is that they often think about
accessibility many years down the line
the earlier that it is done the easier
it is to fix problems the more scale you
have the harder it gets to retrofit
solutions and it's not just
accessibility I think it goes to so many
other problems that society is facing
the longer that they are dealt with the
bigger they get so the earlier you can
address some of these things in my view
the better something that I'm really
passionate about is actually doing what
we can to hire people with disabilities
it's a massively underserved and under
tapped in community of talent and
resource and where possible there's so
many amazing and talented people looking
for roles and I think not just on the
accessibility front it also then gives
you fantastic insights and lived
experience on developing products and
finally as much as invest
thing in this area is the right thing to
do I also hope people see this as like
an amazing opportunity from a business
perspective as well that this is an
underserved need and the best
entrepreneurial opportunities often come
from needs that are underserved and so
if you are thinking for entrepreneurial
ideas to think of this community as
something where you could build
solutions for and on that note thank you
from from sort of me and my team that's
my email address and Twitter handle like
welcome any questions that it'll be
today or any time ever I'm love being
able to help people build things
whenever I can so feel free to to reach
out to me and thank you I think we have
some time for questions if anyone if
anyone has any
sure it is it's an interesting
experience it's something again like
there are there are some benefits and
some drawbacks you know when you are a
smaller company there is a very
different process to building things but
when you are in a larger company yet you
have to collaborate across many
different teams and things have a lot
more process for good reason so that was
very much you know a massive learning
curve for me to get used to but like
with anything it's a different stage of
the lifecycle of a product and there's
been a great learning experience for me
to be able to work on product where you
do have sort of Airbnb size scale I
think there's also just on a very human
level you go from working with a team
where we can all fit around the same
table and now you're in a big building
with thousands and thousands of people
it's yeah it's a it's a very
awe-inspiring experience where you feel
much part of something much bigger and
that was you know as mentioned a bit
earlier in the talk was probably what
drove us to do this was that you know we
could get that excitement that we can
actually be part of something bigger and
take what we were doing to a much more
global audience
yeah question right here hey speaking
about sorry no no it's all good
the guard stood like human experience
and thank you for the talk
just wondering about sort of like any
really like human challenges that tested
your vision and sort of your Road it's
sort of your path because you spoke to a
lot of like sort of Awesome steps but
just curious more about some like really
big sort of personally testing and
vision testing challenges the question
ok so thank you for the question so the
question here was where there were any
sort of challenges to our bigger vision
did I understand the question correctly
um there were a couple of things so on
one level at the very beginning I did
think a lot about you know when you
create a website like this for people
with disabilities is it the right thing
that this is like a separate website so
you know I've always been a great
believer in sort of integration and
mainstreaming things and I did in the
early days think a lot about whether you
know are we doing the right thing
building a standalone platform in itself
I think in hindsight it was a great way
to prove the concept and to prove some
fundamental hypotheses but that yes it
is better to do this as part of a wider
organization in terms of other
challenges to the vision I'd say there
are more just unlike the operational
level again often things just didn't
work to plan whether it be like it's on
the website breaking down or whether you
know you're dealing with challenges of
like of onboarding new hosts and getting
information the right information from
them so I think it's less about the
vision the the main stumbling blocks
actually become more in egg in execution
and just trying to sort of overcome all
of these daily challenges of building a
product where you you know you don't
really have much funding everyone is
stretched yeah you feel like you're
never more than a day from you know
running out of money or some big
disaster on the horizon but at the same
time trying to sort of grow and scale
something
that is yeah effectively still very
fragile so I'd say in the the challenges
and obstacles are more more on that
front rather than on sort of challenges
to the bigger vision it was a question
at the front so the question is I
mentioned earlier a lot about going
beyond compliance and making products
usable and the question is about sort of
is how we can best do that and so how we
can take that further did I understand
the question correctly so I definitely
think that's been a major challenge and
I do think like rules and a lot of it
the basic kind of guidance in place
doesn't need to be developed I think a
lot of rules what a lot of guidance
notes were created in an era sort of
before the internet and I do think when
you are having things like the sharing
economy or like sort of the tech and
real world sort of merging together I do
think at a societal level yes we do need
to have a rethink about what new
standards could be also many rules and
guidance sort of notes that sort of done
very much thinking about the world
divided up by sort of national borders
and in a sort of a tech world that you
know it is where you can I don't know
communicate with somebody in another
country or or use a product to travel to
a different place at the click of a
button I think again we do need to think
about how do we build standards at a
more global level that I think will
actually make it easier for a lot more
organizations and companies to do this
what advice do you have for budding you
know product managers especially you
know there's a debate between by the
line it should be an engineering
background yeah I I mean I so the
question here is about sort of as a
product manager and in backgrounds and
sort of what what might work best like I
do think it often depends on the product
that you are managing also slightly just
to turn the question a little bit like I
do think those product manager skills
are very dependent on what exactly you
are building like I do think like if the
product is very very deeply technical
naturally having a sort of engineering
background I think makes life easier
whether if it's if it's something less
technical and more about kind of user
experience and sort of the flows and the
onboarding then I think there are other
skills that that can become really
helpful as well and we think there's
also the matter of like what the life
cycle of the product is as well so I
don't think there is a one-size-fits-all
answer I think was a huge number of
variables in this I'm for my own
personal perspective I think having
experience from lots of different areas
has helped me a huge amount whether it
be having sort of that business
background that helps me talk to like
our operations and sort of business team
or actually you know having a little bit
of technical skill myself has made it
much easier to work with engineers and
designers is that knowing a little bit
about a lot of things has has personally
been really valuable because I think
yeah that's probably it's something that
I think is very valuable particularly
when you're working on something on
early stage and you're just having input
from lots of different specialists but
again I think it's one of those
questions unfortunately you are sort of
50 different product managers you
probably get 50 different 50 different
answers
uh-oh
I really love the diversity having a
team in terms of perspectives I was just
curious as you evolving your company if
you uncovered any flights boss a pertain
to densify so the question was did we
have like as you can see sort of
diversity was really important as we
were building our company and now in our
own team were there any blind spots did
I understand the question correctly any
blind spots um so we there were some
blind spy
so let's blind spots it was more that
things we knew that we could do better
but at the time during the startup we
just didn't have the resources to do so
we were very well aware that there were
certain types of disabilities that we
were more focused on and that we were
kind of you know optimizing for in terms
of building product when actually
there's so many other other use cases
that we felt we could do more for so
less of a blind spot there were just a
lot of aspirational things that we
wanted to do better but just didn't have
the resource at the time and again yeah
it's one of those things where you sort
of have to make those trade-offs as a
founder but at the same but it's it's
trade-offs but knowing that those
trade-offs are part of a bigger vision
where it's still really important and
you will just get to it at a slightly
later stage
so billion products products are
overlooked demographics that make
sometimes feel a little different and I
kind of went to know what your
experience was when it comes to getting
your first view champion and so first to
investors when you're building something
so the question is sort of what we were
thinking about when we were sort of
because we were building for an
underserved community who it was the
question how did we what were the
champions on the first view what was our
experience with the first few champions
so for those who we were building for
very quickly got what we were trying to
do I think that is the great thing about
when you are helping an underserved
community the underserved community will
immediately often recognize okay this is
this is something we really need I think
for us the bigger challenge was trying
to persuade wider society that this is
important especially in things like
fundraising you're pitching to people
who may not have had that personal
experience or have come across these
situations before and I think that for
us was the biggest challenge there was
less champions within our community it
was more finding folks who could support
us amongst the wider entrepreneurial
ecosystem so in our early days of
fundraising we had a lot of struggles
with people thinking that there wasn't a
business opportunity here this is not
really a need this is just something
very simple that other companies are
gonna do whereas actually our lead
investor had a son with a disability and
the minute he saw what we were doing is
like I get it I know this is really
important so in answer to your question
like champions within our community were
pretty easy to come by I just feel like
I wish we had more champions at the time
within like the wider world
[Applause]